Donald Trump under fire once again
former Miss California USA
Tammy Farrell penned a lengthy message
to her Facebook page detailing the words
she allegedly overheard the morning she
earned the crown
Tammy claims during a conference call
Trump said quote I don't know who this
new girl is but I don't want her doing
interviews she's unattractive and she
sounds stupid
um-um-um that's what she sounds like
doing interviews while she eventually
took the title Tammy recalls one day
receiving a package from Trump it was
this photo copy of Tammy in a swimsuit
for a magazine
she writes I didn't know if I should
laugh or cry it didn't matter who I was
or what I had done my beauty had
received his stamp of approval meanwhile
Marlee Matlin a former Celebrity
Apprentice contestant is responding to
recent reports Trump mocked her for
being deaf and called her [ __ ] via
fire Marley did not confirm nor deny
Trump made the insensitive remarks but
offered this
it's not about insults or taking each
other down as a person who is deaf as a
woman as a mom as a wife as an actor I
have a voice and I'm using that voice to
make myself heard and vote